hola a todos aquí hablaré de lo que es
la derivada direccional y esta es en
realidad una idea que pretende extender
la noción de derivada parcial
así que si recordamos lo que es una
derivada parcial tiene que ver con con
una función de varias entradas así que
aquí voy a considerar una función solo
de dos entradas para que sea mucho más
simple ok y vamos a tener digamos una
sola salida digamos podría ser x
cuadrada por ye muy bien entonces una
forma en la que siempre podemos pensar a
estas funciones es digamos que aquí
tengamos nuestro nuestro espacio de
entradas digamos este es el plano x de
verdad este es nuestro espacio de
entradas y entonces tenemos que esta
función esencialmente transforma este
espacio de entradas
otro espacio verdad que es el espacio de
salidas verdad entonces nosotros podemos
considerar la derivada parcial de
nuestra función con respecto a x por
ejemplo verdad y podríamos pensarlo en
algún punto particular el 1,2 entonces
aquí estará el 1 aquí está el 1 y luego
2 nos colocamos en este punto y para
poder pensar en la derivada parcial de
la función en este punto si estamos
pensando en la derivada con respecto a x
entonces pensamos en un pequeño
empujoncito en la dirección x y nos
fijamos cómo es que ese pequeño cambio
influye en nuestra salida entonces
calculamos digamos cuál es esa
influencia verdad vemos ese resultado en
el espacio de salidas y después hacemos
la proporción entre este cambio y este
cambio verdad y eso es esencialmente el
valor que buscamos y también podríamos
haber hecho esto mismo pero con la
dirección de verdad entonces pudimos
haber hecho este empujoncito en la
vertical vemos cómo es que esto afecta a
nuestra función en el espacio de salidas
y nuevamente calculamos la proporción
verdad ahora bien vamos a considerar una
idea muy muy parecida y esencialmente es
la pregunta que aborda la derivada
direccional por ejemplo si nosotros
consideramos un vector digamos un vector
b y le ponemos esta flechita aquí arriba
para indicar que es un vector este
vector ve digamos que sea el menos 1 2
muy bien aquí tenemos el vector menos 12
verdad si nosotros anclamos este vector
desde este punto entonces digamos
tendremos menos uno y luego subimos dos
más o menos sería este vector que apunta
en esta dirección verdad entonces
nosotros podríamos pensar exactamente
igual que con las derivadas parciales
podríamos pensar que le hace a la
función un pequeño empujoncito en la
dirección de este vector
y recordemos que estos son esencialmente
cambios infinitamente pequeños verdad es
decir formalmente estaríamos pensando en
el límite verdad de la proporción entre
los cambios así que podríamos pensar
entonces en multiplicar este vector b
por una constante h digamos aquí
tendríamos h por nuestro vector de
verdad y formalmente lo que tendríamos
que hacer es tomar el límite cuando h
tiende a cero entonces uno podría
incluso considerar valores muy muy
pequeños para nuestra h verdad pero
formalmente tomaremos el límite cuando h
tiende a cero verdad así así la dire
derivada direccional nos dice cuál sería
el cambio en la salida de nuestra
función al tener un empujoncito en la
dirección de nuestro vector b entonces
para este caso particular podríamos
simplemente multiplicar al vector b por
h eso nos daría en la primera coordenada
sería menos h y en la segunda coordenada
tendríamos
2 h muy bien entonces nuestra nosotros
podríamos intentar dar una una noción de
lo que es la derivada direccional en la
dirección de nuestro vector b verdad y
la anotación para para escribir esto
sería justamente usar nuestro
triangulito invertido que usamos para
para la derivada para para el gradiente
perdón y le ponemos un subíndice b que
va a indicar la dirección en la que
estamos tomando esta derivada y esto lo
aplicamos a nuestra función f que
depende de x y entonces de aquí
podríamos más o menos dar una idea de
cómo es este cambio verdad sería menos
una vez el cambio en la dirección x
verdad más o menos podríamos tratar de
adivinar qué es esto menos una vez el
cambio en la dirección x que podríamos
representarlo con la derivada parcial y
luego tendríamos que sumar dos veces el
cambio en la dirección el cambio de f
con respecto
de verdad sería como nuestro primer
intento para tratar de decir quién es
entonces si nosotros nos ponemos un
poquito más abstractos y consideramos un
vector w
en general digamos con coordenadas a y
ve muy bien esto es digamos un poquito
más general entonces ahora lo que
podríamos hacer es calcular la derivada
direccional de nuestra función con en la
dirección del vector w verdad y esto
sería a veces el cambio de la función
con respecto a x + b veces el cambio de
la función con respecto a iu y éste es
digamos nuestra fórmula que podríamos
utilizar para calcular la derivada
direccional en la dirección del vector w
entonces resumiendo nosotros tomamos a
veces un aumento con respecto a x y b
veces el aumento
digamos con respecto a ella verdad
entonces está esta fórmula a veces se ve
escrita de forma digamos más compacta
podremos tomar una forma más compacta de
escribir esto y que en realidad se ve
como un producto punto verdad aquí esta
formulita nos dice que hay un producto
punto por ejemplo podríamos tomar el
vector ave y hacer el producto punto con
el vector que tiene componente parcial
de f con respecto a equis y parcial de f
con respecto a ye muy bien entonces
ahora notemos que en realidad este
vector es el vector w que es la
dirección en la cual estamos moviéndonos
verdad y hacemos el producto punto con
este otro vector que si notamos muy bien
esto es el gradiente de nuestra función
verdad entonces esta es la fórmula
compacta para la derivada direccional y
por eso es que me gusta mucho esta
anotación que tenemos aquí en realidad
podríamos haber tomado otra anotación
por ejemplo pudimos haber utilizado
que a veces se escribe que se ve como
parcial del df con respecto a este
lector o también pudimos haber utilizado
esta otra anotación y es por esta
fórmula que me gusta mucho esta primera
anotación que hemos elegido porque nos
sugiere mucho cómo calculamos la
derivada direccional y así es como lo
verás en algunos libros de texto digamos
como como una forma compacta de
escribirlo y de hecho puedes ver cómo es
que esta fórmula verdad se puede
extender a más dimensiones por ejemplo
si tenemos una entrada de cinco
dimensiones verdad por ejemplo si
tenemos un vector de cinco dimensiones
como valor de entrada y el vector
digamos en el cual nos movemos tiene
cinco componentes entonces podemos hacer
este producto punto verdad entonces en
resumen la derivada direccional nos dice
cómo cambiaría la función al tomar
pequeños en pocos empujoncitos en cierta
dirección vemos cómo cambia la salida de
nuestra función y luego tomamos esa
proporción así que en el siguiente vídeo
voy a clarificar mucho más la definición
formal de
direccional